доброго дня шину та товариство я клавіші
ви прийшли сьогодні на наш брифінг та
моторі нашого брифінгу ті дізнаємося але не
was ist im і праворуч ми але не просто
сталін виправляйте займайся тим
опікується міністерство святі науки али
також я б хоч і пристави ти вам за
галину логіку то чому самі цілі нашої
ми займаємося і я думаю ще калли
буде 100 днів у тозі ми будемо розвиненого
ти створити з правої али зараз на моєму
це е піцу ми в пекло і тягнемо і спрацює
шукаємо і ближньому годині обов'язково моєму
забуті
він же до концептуальних намагалися
належить наші закони на таку роботу
ви знає ще в пішому а що то не я був
ухвалений закон вище святого atween
абсолютно важливі buy win нічний світ та
революційний вин базу і тин і демерс
тайської автономії у тому числі фінансово
економічний урок за тійною і ми
силоміць зміню йому всі правила в середині
у стерти вище та почти то там і з форуму
про цепова наву ситуації з і закон важливі
у засіки
атакою що чоловік вин проектуватися на
середню почет і настане законопроект на
таким ми починаємо впросила тец і закон
про свиту
який включаючи всі ви харчування з метою
свити
дужки але і по вежі але і почет там ще
закон для вищого світу виставляє хлопці
стандарти і привели в море до середньої us
with ще по винос на ти ними ти випускник
школи для того, щоб стати успішним
студентом той хто нас тут ний закон це
буде закон про середню свиту
і ми з подіємо ще в травмі місяці
буде прийнятий закон про ви ще квітів
іншому че-то не і тут на кіно і
порівняємо обираємо атакував цю
конференцію будем роботи обговорення
збору їм за всіх регіонах у 4 експертів
тільки уважно києва світячись кого
середовищем щоки так наші молитви немає
середню святі і ми будемо вже обоє
варівати основні тези положення закону
про право свиту the pta 1000 тусуйся
середні святі і ще один законник з
знаходиться в полі нашого візерунка, але таким
такий
процу і moze закон про науку і ну-ка
виділялися там ще
загальна концерті я такий ще не могли
б розвивати її не науку без вищі
святині не ви ще світла без науки то там
і цим чоловікам ви не інтеграли від і
науку та почет
з концептуально навіть важливо його ось і
працюй полях а я в тому ще
україна це пост рівненської околиці в
дикі зберегла серця система
національної академії наук
я канави подавався ще європейський годинник
томи та сама національної академії наук
шукай шлях у реформуванні ми знаємо і
Петро і майма діалог ми також про
подавали
був відмові від його проведення спільної
засідання відбудеться національної
академії наук та колегії міністерства
святі науки csf контексті роботи над
законом про науку та наукова діяльність
той тест 3 законопроекти ці навички мами
про в'язницю та ближні я думаю і все
реально покажчик ближніх трієру
лижник Європи будуть присвячені саме
цим законом далі ми тілком змінюваної
систем або зв'язування та кардит архиза
раз на нашому веб-сайті міністерства
світлі науки ви можете побачити нові
розумом або зв'язування ікар дотації від і
зарості давайте граматика займання
ближньої години а ближньої години мети
думаємо вузли його на нас тут нам також
на ній ми вже правильному шляху постанови та
про
поліси звання та з акредитації зміст
замість їх реформ я таки ще систем або
зв'язування кредит азії будуть означати
матчем з простіше не цегла державних
служба fcew обох про що чиновники в
інших треба буде згорнути з і потім з
праху ніями
всяких з будда значно жінка від
прощення систем або зв'язування до
результаті не означає менше не в махно
у паку в і логін з меншої царівни
стоїть тиш проділами і відразу милими і
циви боги тусується без побудови
професіонал діяльності барана і я кисея
там фар манери відсіки в принципі молоком
молоко груповими цокають і топ то
системи для зв'язування кредиту
найближчі до
європейських у мох і коли і буде
ухвалений закон для вищого світла
системи лісу звання колись типу ви на
концептуально зерна то системи вибір на
лику прополюватиму і новий закон про
ви ще свиту так само і тесту метушні
середньої школи та вищої школи ми означає
ми запитаємо сповістити там вже вибач якщо
апарат творчих і наші люди називають
вона забралася вже дуже багато години
його на вигляд залучала по суті увага і
читали ви call дачі у та каналі без
посередник взуття скіф під логічних і
професіях менше хабарівських викладок
ських тямущих вигляд це можуть розвинути
внесеного нас прощається і етики в
середній школі
decibel а вид святого не ми зірки років
тут вид поведено на 10000 позицій
тисяч вбили тисячі позицій тату не треба
буде не треба буде
скажімо про ми не будемо забуті у форматі
ico повз і без останнього практичного
заслуховування але про клопі я cable 1
туалет і я вставляються
сенсу пакети і такі ніші тофу ціль
знайти промови вікі-віки ми в польшу черепа
ви не з вини в магате
так вже ми вату йому нову постановку ряду
про ви знання західних дипломів
топ то в чому тут проблема ви знаєте
такі терміни я критик низьких brain
drain
дикі ведений і навіть натякається у нас
над ще ми зустрічаємо багата молодих
ефективний і закінчувати університети та
йдуть штука роботи його продовжив ти на
вч вони на заході ось ми забуваємо ще ctr
медуза провалений владики британії
після друга з цього чи іншого коліван і
побачили ще їх не добрий випускники
бачиш айдос отриманих штаті абаші до ти
там працював би продовжив піна втягне
адже сцена походить не врятував транс кого
просто розлука та британії
і ми часто забуваємо а ще моїми з в рот
не процес скелі люди навчаються на
на заході від тримали там а я пензель на якій
щаблі в чині телефонуючи і намагаються назад і
зайшли в чималі волоки проблеми з ви
знанням ніяких дипломів тут від злих і
відривала та принесла вам процедура
нострифікації але наша ідея так а ще ми
будемо, але ви знову ти університети зможе
дізнаватись дипломи дипломи 100 краще
університеті в святий отець з так росії
100 карасик університеті ми будемо
адресувати донною красиво колірних
рейтингу таких як шанхайський на
прокладка це так то я ще й диплом
вона про клад проза кеничі не пізді тату
докторської програми в одному з красивих
разом з виглядом-то з диплом буде у нас
визнавати
і тут нічого страшного найму і там ще
коли у нас люди закінчувати університети
йдуть на захід сонця проти ти виходиш і б
вклади і простіше у почет людей йти
просити найгіршу економікою сині
держави даним випад до і всі хто
і з дипломом праведні західних
університетах проїхавши чіпа повернувся до
україну і просив нас і означають те
є внесок у гаю їхньому святому на буду
засовувати і тут хтось порожньо нова
карта клаптя дуже важливо і
і як я думаю легко на i'coo давно
відсікає наші з витян і так ось я хочу
сказати ще ми змінили гриф його нею
підручний київ для вищі школи
міністерством а квіти все праворуч усередині
клану в чині раді університетів і ти їх
податкових установка ці підручники
писалися а і чим і словами і держава не
тисніть на контроль і нагрів way to the
nice хвалили тут руку набряки на
постраждаємо кому просто ри-ре кисть
кисть підручнику топ то ще така
державу з хвали в цілі грошей то він
розуміє тому в даному випуску ми порада
побачили з прикладу йому на сальні
університети і я хочу я вважав
у чині розхвалювати йдуть руку такі
підручнику ікебану з професіями точки
зірка
низької яскравості ми залишатимемося
харчування прайаг є на tickets я вчора
dlc універсі
це б університеті нас за багато і cbd
один з критеріїв таких рахунок мотив
претензії дати ялинової університету тому
шкіра на місце в чому рада шкіра у неї
варто згадувати дума ти ось і по ви над
бате protection і видають підручнику ланцюга
друг ніккі по ви не but i я кістами я
тут і
і з підручником та середні школи в
середній школі не могли його повністю вигляд
мавля тася у вигляді до з централізовані
системи
нібито прогадала сипить рушники нібито
було вигляд брала рукописи забавляло рукою
після такого вже цього ми про фільми про
в'язницю і з званим експертом з
романськими організаціями і мною та ближнім
годину він представлений
граматику структуру нібито приносимо було
б професіонали закладену в тому числі
до міністерства святі науки і наново
ново так організації як проти лапід
контролем грамоті кістки в вона б
та проґавила з рукописами за автором та
його щоб за крима схоплювала підручнику
тут руку шкільні підручнику тут-то ми
хочемо отримати цю граматики ніж по
треба допомагала міністерство почту від с
професією найточки зору і значать
якими ви не пляшка підручнику для шкіл
для шкіл від неї і я до них треба доводить
йдуть руку вид замовлення так та друг у
1100 суеца коротше тяглася гадів киньте
травня в концентрат ми проводитимемо
завтра which is a світячи нами середньої
школи cdr нас виникла у херсоні я був у
херсон недавно на хвилин і чекай знаєте я
буду херсоне ось і ми малі та доброго
навіть засвіти нам і село тіла та області
від усього було в Херсонському університеті та
cdma свинок у цьому ще й багато
пропозицій бата ідей али у нас на
порядку даного першими д закон про
вищого світла на ступні будуть закон про
світла і тому ми збираємо з регіонів
експерти was within для того щоб
напоготові б
провести таку посмішку на роду і вже про
ту займатися
законом просвітлена з херсоном такий у нас
пов'язана
прив'язаний ідейки промови за організацію
сонячне складно оцінювання думаєте а на
базі ви знаєте ще сонячно та складно
оцінювання
центр називається
центр оцінювання регіональний центр
оцінювання кістки усвяти
кримський вин припаяли свої підстави там
ще все приміщення було закуплено
по бандитський захід місяця цьому мета
центр регіональних ми переносимо 1
херсона
ми вже малий розмова в Херсоні самому і
з клинком обласної адміністрації ми
малі розміри та засвіти нам і там де
Петро їм кота мене злити його виділено
приміщення найближчим годинником цього будемо
обласного ти наш регіональний центр
1100 suite від і статив від і стати і для
випускників дев'ятих та одинадцятих
класів з автономної республіки крим set
is the також вигляд іншого не та води вже
за в зоні до криму нині будуть видавати
десяток званим міністерство mosfet
екрану та води будуть видаватися барани
будуть видаватися районними бачила святих
за великим кисть з них від і стати і в
4820 так само важливі ще на стадії
завершення у нас робота над новими
критеріями державний цієї статті шкіль
вигляді основі будуть неформальні поки що
знаки топ туги класі вікі площі
землі і такі менше кільки з міду
листя а в основі
з їхнього критерію вкласти від синього дня я
кістки реальності падаючі колективу топ
то тактики вирахувати і так і середню
світимо з рота і можу я червоно на профі
сильно на професійність вони keys
формальний формальних критеріїв